Now let us suppose that the AI
program had background knowledge,
which said that brick is a kind of block
and wedge is a kind of block as well.
In that case, the AI program may
use this background knowledge to
further revise this current concept
definition and replace this brick or
wedge by a block, because both bricks
and wedges are examples of blocks.
So we'll call this
a climb-tree heuristic.
Here is a tree of background knowledge,
we're climbing the tree.
Note another interesting aspect of this.
Suppose that there was under the kind of
block that was possible, say a cylinder.
So now that the AI program has
generalized from brick and
wedge into a block, and
this is the current definition.
If a new example comes along and
it has a cylinder at the top here,
that would be covered by
this particular concept.
And this AI program would be able to
recognize that particular instance which
had the cylinder at the top as
an example of this concept definition.
That is the power of being able to use
this background knowledge to generalize.
The more we know, the more we can learn.
>> So it sounds like this is actually
an example of what I was doing earlier.
I had said that because
I saw a brick and
a cylinder both playing the same role,
that they were both examples of block.
And therefore,
any block could play that role.
Then when I saw that funny kind of
little arch shape holding up
the block on top, I inferred that
that would also be an acceptable
answer because both brick and
cylinders were blocks.
And I generalized out to say
any block could play that role.
>> Good connection, David.